we've taken every single box score from
the original very first NBA game and
we've put it into our database and so
now you can actually take a game that
happened last night and compare that
performance against a Michael Jordan
game back in the 1990's or a Larry Bird
game or Magic Johnson game or a kareem
abdul-jabbar game so it gives people
perspective to say okay I know that
LeBron James had a pretty good game but
how did that compare against some of the
other former players and people have
real time access to information but it's
technology that helps enable that
because now the technology exists and
the infrastructure is it exists to
create and crunch this data in real time
getting it to the fans and consumers
quicker than we've ever been able to do
during this playoffs we actually have
been delivering real-time clips from our
games via Twitter into people's feeds
and they're able to open up those clips
and it creates some real time excitement
for the game so if you see a great
player if you see that the game is
coming down to the wire and you get this
Twitter video of NBA footage then you're
inclined to go and turn on the TV and
watch it or turn on your digital device
and watch the game through our game time
application or any other mobile
application that you have
just the other day during the Miami Heat
indiana pacers game sixty-five percent
of all social media conversations were
around that game and so fans when
there's that dual screen experience that
when fans are watching our games they're
also interacting with each other through
Twitter through Facebook and they're
talking about the game in a very social
way you know we talk about the water
cooler and I think the NBA creates this
digital water cooler talk but instead of
the next morning around the water cooler
it's happening real time in in this what
we call digital water cooler so the NBA
is sparking those conversations in the
social media space amongst our fans
every night of the week